from the rainforests of Thailand to the
boreal forests of Siberia trees combat
climate change by pulling carbon dioxide
out of the atmosphere as they grow in
addition to regulating the climate
forests also nurture biodiversity but
today their ability to provide these
benefits is waning
trees evolved over millions of years to
withstand fire droughts insects disease
but even resilience has its limits
extreme drought combined with other
stressors can turn insect infestations
deadly slaying mighty hemlocks and pines
in North America and the lack of
moisture can transform a tree into a
tinderbox in the far north drought and
fire plague the boreal forests of Canada
Siberia and Alaska these forests
normally trap vast amounts of carbon but
now warmer summers are shutting the
trees down reducing photosynthesis
intense wildfires are clearing the land
allowing new tree species to replace
those that affirmed in the tropics the
pressure to clear trees for agriculture
grazing and mining has fragmented vast
tracts of rainforest compromising
biodiversity the health of the planet
depends on the health of its forests but
today only a fraction of forests remain
undisturbed by humans still some
scientists and policymakers think that
degraded and secondary forests will be a
vital source of forest cover in the
future and others say we need a
comprehensive forest health care plan
for the 21st century it will require
more than just protecting old-growth
forests it also will require
rehabilitating disturbed and recovering
forests